[Musik]
die nächte sind dunkel geworden in
beirut strom gibt es nur für wenige
stunden
benzin und diesel für die generatoren
sind knapp im libanon an den tankstellen
stehen die menschen stunden für ein paar
liter plötzlich herrscht aufregung weil
ein paar männer benzin in
plastikkanister füllen eine schiitische
miliz kontrolliert hier die zapfsäulen
erst sollen wir die kameras wegpacken
dann verbreiten sie doch lieber ihre
propaganda das ist falsch
was ist das problem mit dem benzin mir
kein englisch spricht arabisch bitte
unser problem sind die zionisten
das ist das hauptproblem sonst würden
wir in wohlstand und frieden leben
die amerikaner und die zionisten sind
schuld an den problemen im libanon
applaus für den anführer
die clans übernehmen die macht im
libanon ein jahr nach der katastrophe im
hafen von beirut dicke wirtschaft in
trümmern
der staat ist in auflösung
[Musik]
unglaublich was man nach einem jahr noch
smid der unternehmer allegri führt mich
zum ort der explosion
das ausmaß der gewalt ist kaum zu
begreifen
das ist der speicher er hat einen
großteil der stadt vor noch schlimmerem
bewahrt wissen wir nach einem jahr warum
es passiert ist
wir können immer noch nicht die genauen
gründe warum es passiert ist und leider
bekommen wir in einem land mit so viel
korruption und politischen problemen auf
die meisten dinge keine wirkliche
antwort 2700 tonnen ammoniumnitrat
lagerten über jahre ungeschützt im hafen
von der versicherung bekommt erst dann
eine entschädigung wenn die regierung
ihren abschlussbericht vorlegt er hat
große zweifel dass die hintergründe ans
licht kommen werden im hafen haben alle
regierungs gruppen ihren einfluss alle
sekten im land haben den hafen unter
sich aufgeteilt
sie alle haben hier ihre finger im spiel
und niemand niemand hat etwas
unternommen
autoteile möbel parfümflaschen alles was
alle hier lagerte wurde fast vollständig
zerstört
zum glück sagt er mir waren seine 50
angestellten zum zeitpunkt der explosion
bereits zu hause so ein geschoss
was wären alle begraben worden aber
niemand war da zum glück waren die man
tiere es gab eine corona ausgangssperre
ab 4 uhr und die explosion war um kurz
nach sechs siegen kurve wegen der
ausgangssperre mussten wir alle um 4
gehen womit leben gerettet auf gewisse
weise
dann zeigt mir immer seine wohnung die
gleich neben dem hafen liegt dass auf
dem balkon stand um das feuer zu filmen
hätte ihn fast das leben gekostet
sekunde habe ich mich leicht gedreht und
wurde ins haus geschleudert
das ganze glas ist auf mich gefallen
wenn ich stehen geblieben wäre dann wäre
ich wohl gefallen
kaum zu glauben welch glück im unglück
erler hatte und fassbar vor allem wenn
man dazu die bilder sieht das ist der
film den ich genau hier aufgenommen habe
[Musik]
das ist meine frau durchschreiten
hilfen vom staat hat es kaum gegeben
an vielen häusern sind die spuren der
explosion noch immer zu sehen
es sind nachbarn die dabei helfen sie zu
reparieren
in einer leerstehenden tankstelle
bereiten josephine und ein paar freunde
seit der explosion mahlzeiten zu ein
paar wochen wollten sie helfen aber die
situation wird von tag zu tag schlimmer
wir dachten das trauma und die folgen
würden mit der zeit nachlassen aber wir
haben gemerkt dass sich durch die
wirtschaftskrise immer mehr menschen bei
uns melden
es kommt alles zusammen die kurve
situation die politische situation die
gesundheitslage die engpässe bei den
apotheken und krankenhäusern bei
nahrungsmitteln wächst der
versorgungsmangel mit jedem tag 250
frische portionen kochen sie jeden tag
finanziert aus spenden
wir haben zu schaffen das merke ich ja
sich josephine eine weile bei der
ausgabe unterstütze dankbarkeit spüre
ich bei allen walid lebt allein und
erzählt mir dass er die schwere zeit
ohne die hilfe der nation station nicht
durchgestanden hätte
ich bin der organisation so dankt sie
haben sich um mich gekümmert und mir
sehr geholfen
nach der explosion hatte ich fünf tage
nichts zu essen und zu trinken
sie haben ihr medikamente gebracht die
wohnung repariert und so viel mehr
ich bin ihnen sehr dankbar der bedarf an
hilfe ist mittlerweile so hoch dass
josephine die rationen begrenzen muss
nur noch jeden zweiten tag gibt es für
walid eine warme mahlzeit einigen
älteren aus der nachbarschaft bringt sie
das essen auch nach hause von der
regierung erwartet sie nichts mehr
der libanon glaubt sie kann nur im
kleinen gerettet werden
es gibt ein vor und ein nach der
explosion nach der explosion hat sich
alles verändert wenn wir noch einen
funken vertrauen oder hoffnung in unser
system und die politiker hatten ist der
erloschen
die explosion hat alles zerstört
das wenige geld das sei niemals
schneider verdiente hat immer zum leben
gereicht
ohne hilfe müsste er heute vier tage
arbeiten um eine mahlzeit zu bezahlen
im libanon leiden wir jeden tag die
menschen legen sich schlafen und
wünschten sie würden nicht aufwachen
wir wünschten wir wären tot tot ist
besser als dieser tage zu erleben
ich esse einmal am tag ist alles was ich
mache ist kaffee trinken und zigaretten
auch in einem kleinen verschlag von zwei
quadratmetern lebt und arbeitet für uns
heute seine wut hervor und singt von der
schönheit des mondes und von der liebe
was müsste er sich selbst daran erinnern
[Musik]
st
ein jahr nach der explosion hat das land
keine funktionsfähige regierung
religionsgruppen dem bürgerkrieg als
milizen kämpfen sollen gemeinsame
lösungen finden
doch die parteien der christen der
sunniten schiiten und rosen sind heillos
zerstritten
in seinem streng gesicherten haushoch
über beirut empfängt mich de brasil ein
christ und vorsitzender der grössten
partei des landes schwiegersohn des
präsidenten selbst mehrfach minister und
teil der politischen elite die
mitverantwortlich ist für die krise im
land
[Musik]
sprechen wir über die explosion wie ist
das möglich dass es ein jahr später
immer noch kein bericht und keine
verantwortlichen gibt es ist einfach
festzustellen wo beamte fahrlässig
gehandelt
das lässt sich herausfinden und es gab
bereits erste verhaftung leute sind im
gefängnis da tut sich etwas zu klären
wer die explosion verursacht hat das ist
schwieriger wir hatten ein wenig hilfe
von den usa und aus europa aber sie
haben uns nicht wirklich mit den nötigen
informationen versorgt weder mit
satellitenbildern noch mit
geheimdienstinformationen
ich bin überzeugt dass es da eine
größere verschwörung gibt um zu
vertuschen wäre für die explosion
verantwortlich ist das ist die explosion
des jahrzehnts und niemand kann mir
weismachen dass so eine gewaltige
explosion vertuscht werden kann doch
niemand etwas gesehen
sie glauben dass andere länder und nicht
sie selbst verantwortlich sind
das sage ich nicht ich sage uns wurde
nicht wirklich geholfen
das wurde von einer seite verursacht
hier hat es ausgelöst
und da liegt das größte problem im
libanon die korruption
es gibt keine verantwortlichkeit und
keine konsequenzen
wir sehen immer wieder dasselbe korrupte
verhalten bei niemand dafür ins
gefängnis wandert niemand wird angeblich
niemand muss zurücktreten für
gräueltaten und korruption
sie wollten die herrschaft der warlords
und der milizen beenden
sind sie gescheitert in einer demokratie
reicht es nicht aus die grösste partei
zu haben den größten block
sie brauchen eine mehrheit und der
libanon hat ein konfessionelle system in
dem die korrupten leider von ihren
religionsgruppen gedeckt werden
es sind dieselben leute sie haben ihre
militär uniformen ausgezogen und ihre
pistolen abgelegt
heute tragen sie verwandten erhalten
einen stift und sie unterschreiben im
namen ihrer mini dieselben die vorher
auf den straßen gekämpft haben kämpfen
heute innerhalb der regierung und
plündern den staat und die bevölkerung
und wie man sie aus diesem teufelskreis
ausbrechen
bedauerlicherweise muss ich sagen hilft
uns der kollaps um den druck auf sie zu
erhöhen damit bestimmte gesetze
verabschiedet und entscheidungen
getroffen werden
sie meinen die milizen die leute die
wirklich an der macht sehen die eine
regierungsmehrheit haben sie haben eine
allianz gebildet und verhindern dass wir
die korruption bekämpfen
sie verhindern dass wir einen staat
aufbauen sie verhindern die reform der
wirtschaft und des finanzsystems sie
verhindern dass wir dass verdorbenes
system durch ein neues ersetzen
ein politiker der sich mir gegenüber als
vorkämpfer gegen die korruption
bezeichnet mit dem finger nur auf andere
zeigt ein politiker der wegen
korruptionsverdacht auf der
sanktionsliste der amerikaner steht sich
als verteidiger nationale interessen
gibt das klingt fast zynisch wir haben
so hart für dieses land gekämpft so viel
blut und so viele seelen verloren
eine schande diese korruption
wir sind unterwegs in einem land in dem
sich die clans der politischen elite
seit jahren schamlos bereichern und sich
hinter betonmauern und stacheldraht vor
dem eigenen volk verstecken
der libanon war schon vor der explosion
in der krise aber jetzt bröckeln die
institutionen
an der corniche der einst zur berühmten
mittelmeer promenade treffe ich muslime
christen und drusen und egal mit wem ich
über die situation im land spreche sie
alle einte wut auf korrupte politiker
die das land ruinieren
wenn die politische elite so weitermacht
und das volk im tiefschlaf bleibt ändert
sich nichts und wir rutschen noch tiefer
in die krise
die politiker wollen alles stehen in
diesem land sie sind nie mit etwas zu
stellen
sie wollen mehr und mehr und mehr geld
die reichtümer im land sind sichtbar
ungleich verteilt und noch nie wurde so
viel kapital aus dem libanon auf
schweizer bankkonten eingezahlt wie im
vergangenen jahr
die bank nimmt libanon hingegen haben
alle konten eingefroren
ersparnisse sind weg die währung ist im
freien fall
der gemüsehändler hussein fakir verkauft
nur noch die billigsten waren tomaten
gurken etwas einheimisches obst
die gemüsepreise steigen im sommer alles
ist viel zu teuer
im winter werden die preise so hoch sein
dass sich niemand mehr essen leisten
kann
wir kämpfen ums überleben um uns selbst
zu versorgen
geschäfte in denen mit lokaler währung
bezahlt wird machen überhaupt keinen
gewinn mehr kunden kaufen nur noch einen
bruchteil der sonstigen menge erzählt
mir hossein und die preise im laden muss
er ständig mit filzstift korrigieren
nicht mal das notwendigste können wir
kaufen 100.000 libanesische grund haben
sonst eine woche gereicht heute nicht
mal mehr eine stunde weil das benzin
fehlt kann sich wusste ihn auch nicht
mehr auf die lieferungen verlassen wenn
er frisches obst oder gemüse braucht
muss er es irgendwie selbst organisieren
jeder will das land verlassen wenn ich
kann gehe ich auch weg es ist vorbei mit
dem was ich verdiene kann ich gerade
benzin plastikkisten und die ladenmiete
zahlen es bleibt nichts übrig der
libanon ist fertig
[Musik]
jahrzehnte der misswirtschaft die
pandemie und dann die hafen explosion
haben den staat handlungsunfähig gemacht
trotz korruption im katastrophe sind die
politischen spitzen noch immer dieselben
in einem café bin ich mit der politik
journalistin kim kraters verabredet
zählt mir zu verstehen warum sich an
diesem system so schnell auch nichts
ändern wird
[Musik]
man spürt die spannung die menschen sind
sehr sehr wütend wie schätzen sie die
lage im libanon ein
ich sehe eine abkopplung der politischen
klasse die das land regiert also den
kleptokraten ehemaligen kriegsherren
milizen führen und ehemaligen
milizenführer eine trennung vom rest der
bevölkerung eine bevölkerung die in der
vergangenheit viel durchmachen musste
und jetzt in einer tiefen krise steckt
diese krise ist beispiele nicht nur für
unser land ich würde sagen für die ganze
welt
warum weil es eine kombination einer
politischen krise ist geht von einer
finanzkrise ausgelöst wurde und
gleichzeitig die wirtschaftskrise weiter
verschärft mit einer politischen klasse
die nicht bereit ist die richtigen
entscheidungen zu treffen
sie sind nicht an reformen interessiert
weil sie vom chaos profitieren vom
schmuggel vom schneeball system auf dem
dieses land aufgebaut ist welche rollen
spielen denn die politischen sekten im
land und wie kann die blockade der
politischen parteien beendet werden
ich glaube dass unsere diversität eine
unserer stärken ist was die politischen
gruppen aber tun ist sie missbrauchen
die diversität um das system zu
blockieren
und sie nutzen die unsicherheit der
menschen um sie an die politischen
führer zu binden
[Musik]
vielleicht geben sie fünf dollar hier
und 100 dollar dar oder einen impfstoff
oder sie besorgen der schwester einen
job und dem vater etwas benzin an der
tankstelle
aber so baut man kein land auf und die
menschen begreifen dass
[Musik]
wer kann flieht vor der krise ins
ausland oder wenigstens raus aus beirut
in die berge oder an die küste von gabun
hier trifft sich die libanesische jugend
und durchzuhalten
nur eine stunde weiter im norden sind
wir gefühlt in einer anderen welt in
einem der vielen privaten strand clubs
treffen wir eine gruppe von freunden auf
demonstrationen wurden sie immer wieder
durch polizeigewalt eingeschüchterte 10
sie mir sie sind müde von den wirren im
land unter der woche versuchen wir zu
arbeiten um wieder auszugleichen was wir
am wochenende ausgeben wir sind im
überlebensmodus und nur so schaffen wir
das wir arbeiten damit wir ausblenden
können was um uns herum passiert obwohl
wir wissen die weniger wir handeln desto
schlimmer wird die lage endlich wieder
schöne momente genießen abschalten
freunde treffen die strände von patronen
sind kleine fluchten weil viele clubs im
bero zeit der explosion geschlossen sind
hat sich die jugend hier ein refugium
geschaffen
ich bin mit lara verabredet dem erzählt
wie wichtig diese orte sind um den
glauben an die zukunft zu bewahren
egal wo man hinschaut gibt es in der
woche spannung
man braucht das hier um den druck zu
entkommen und es ist super wichtig dass
wir die kunst und musikszene im libanon
am leben erhalten
es heißt die libanesen feiern genauso
wie früher
sie sind dabei aber nicht mehr so
glücklich stimmt das es ist auf alle
fälle schwierig an den wochenenden
partys zu feiern und zu versuchen ein
normales leben zu führen wenn um einen
herum das land auseinander bricht sehr
schwer und es wird immer härter so zu
tun als wäre alles normal
wir hangeln uns von tag zu tag wie hat
die explosion denn leben verändert ich
habe eine neu entdeckte wut in mir ich
konnte es nicht fassen dass die
regierung mit keine muskel gezockt hat
nach so einem riesigen ereignis es waren
nachbarn die sofort reagiert und alles
stehen und liegen gelassen haben ich
habe über wochen mitgeholfen und viele
andere sind heute noch dabei und beheben
die schäden
das sind die leute an die ich glaube für
die zukunft des libanon lager hofft dass
eine junge generation in der lage ist
die gräben im land mit der zeit zu
schließen dass die jugend die macht der
politischen sekten und clans irgendwann
brechen kann das eine neue gemeinschaft
entsteht vielleicht an orten wie diesen
die genügend kraft hat für politische
veränderungen wo der staat versagt denn
politische clans häufig die einzigen die
hilfe anbieten
sie versprechen sicherheit
nahrungsmittel und benzin
es sind starten im staate wie diese
schiitenviertel dass die amalthea leeds
und die hisbollah kontrollieren
mehrere bilder hängen überall an den
wänden und hier filmen zu können
brauchen wir viel überzeugungskraft und
ali der gute kontakte zu den beliebten
hat er sorgt dafür dass die menschen mit
mir sprechen auch wenn sie misstrauisch
sind
schnell wird deutlich dass selbst die
politischen sekten keine antwort mehr
haben auf die wut des taxifahrers der
gerade fünf stunden auf benzin warten
musste der grund für die benzinknappheit
sind die politiker sie schmuggeln das
benzin nach syrien
das sind alles liebe es ist nur eine
frage der zeit bis die situation
explodiert früher oder späteren menschen
bereiten sich schon darauf vor es ist
eine frage der zeit
die bäcker können sich importprodukte
kaum noch leisten mehl und öl fairem
einer quiche müssen in dollar bezahlt
werden fast unerschwinglich beim verfall
der eigenen währung weil der dollar
steigt erhöhen auch die großhändler die
preise wir versuchen hier möglichst fair
zu bleiben
aber auch wir müssen über die runden
kommen
auch hier erzählen mir die menschen
offen von ihrer wut auf die politischen
eliten valletta vom sie hatte einen job
und ein haus durch die explosion hat er
beides verloren
er zeigt uns den kiosk in aus fenstern
und bruchstücken auf den trümmern
errichtet hat ihr seht ja dass ich hier
gemüse verkaufe ich muss geld für mich
und meine elfköpfige familie verdienen
natürlich ist das illegal eigentlich
darf ich hier nichts verkaufen
aber auf diesem grundstück stand mein
haus und irgendwie muss ich doch was
verlieren
der hier jeden zu kennen scheint erzählt
mir dass die spannungen im viertel zu
nehmen
mit der krise brücke in alte strukturen
auch das vertrauen in die clans dann
lädt er uns spontan nach hause ein um
seine familie kennenzulernen
der libanon habe sich verändert sagt er
gastfreundschaft gehe verloren wenn
jeder für sich selbst sorgen muss
kichererbsen und okraschoten stehen auf
dem herd fleisch kann sich auch alle
nicht mehr leisten
uns geht es den umständen entsprechend
gut
die wohnung in einem haus während andere
kein dach über dem kopf haben
wir haben genug zu essen für die familie
der libanon ist ein sehr schönes land
aber der libanon verliert seine
schönheit und die menschen sind nicht
mehr so freundlich
überall auf meiner reise stelle ich fest
reden die menschen sehr offen über ihre
unzufriedenheit doch wofür die wut hin
gerät etwas grundsätzliches in bewegung
ist die krise so tiefgreifend dass die
menschen bereit sind neue wege zu gehen
seit fast zwei jahren zeigt die geballte
faust der opposition auf dem
märtyrer-platz in den himmel
im oktober 2009 10 demonstriert mir
tausende über wochen gegen korrupte
eliten und die machtpolitischer sekten
hussain haji war mittendrin ein schiit
der selbst in einem hisbollah viertel
aufgewachsen ist
es war unglaublich so viele menschen die
ohne parteizugehörigkeit auf die straße
gegangen sind
für uns war das der entscheidende moment
der platz glich einem fahnenmeer
noch heute spricht hossein von der power
der revolution aus den aktivisten ist
eine junge oppositionspartei geworden
meinte schrien übersetzt seit oktober
ist eine neue generation von politikern
die clanstrukturen überwinden will
zum ersten mal entsteht gerade eine
koalition aus säkularen jugend
bewegungen und parteien im tischrin zum
beispiel hat hier begonnen
wir waren 19 leute auf der straße ein
jahr später waren wir eine organisierte
bewegung
zwei jahre später sind wir eine
politische partei was ist das ziel von
menschen das große ziel ist der wechsel
zu einem stark der menschenrechte
respekt zu einem säkularen staat zu
einem staat der auf soziale
gerechtigkeit passiert ein staat in dem
sich die menschen wie bürger verhalten
können ohne die vormundschaft einer
sekte oder von irgendeiner ideologischen
gruppe hossein erzählt mir wie sich
wütende menschen kurz nach der explosion
auf dem platz versammelt haben und von
politikern antworten zu verlangen
und wie sie von sicherheitskräften
brutal zusammengeschlagen wurden in
dieser nacht haben wir beschlossen dass
es nicht ausreicht auf die straße zu
gehen wenn man es mit milizen zu tun mit
bewaffneten fraktionen die bereit sind
bis zum äußersten zu gehen um uns brutal
zu unterdrücken
dann reicht das nicht aus wir mussten
anfangen uns politisch zu organisieren
und wir haben beschlossen dass menschen
von einer jugendbewegung zu einer
politischen partei werden muss und an
dem tag haben wir angefangen zu arbeiten
ich habe viele junge menschen getroffen
die das land so schnell wie möglich
verlassen wollen
wollen sie bleiben und ich sage ihnen
warum es entsteht gerade eine neue
politische dynamik und wir müssen ja
eine chance geben sie fragen mich ob ich
das land verlassen
nein ich will nicht gehen aber ich
glaube für uns ist es die letzte chance
einen wandel zu erreichen wenn wir jetzt
keinen erfolg haben
dann werden viele menschen dieses
wunderschöne land am mittelmeer
verlassen
am nächsten morgen lerne ich weitere
mitglieder der jungen partei kennen
musste ihn hat mich in das büro von
münte schrien eingeladen
auch lara die ich in baton getroffen
habe es dabei
sie wollen mich auf eine demonstration
vor dem justizministerium mitnehmen weil
ein jahr nach der explosion noch niemand
zur verantwortung gezogen wurde
das sind unsere plakate für diesen geht
es um die unabhängigkeit der justiz was
uns besonders wichtig ist wir fordern
dass die immunität aufgehoben werden
eine partei die mitglieder aus allen
religiösen gruppen hat im libanon gleich
das schon eine revolution
das vertrauen der wähler zu gewinnen
braucht zeit auf der fahrt erzählen mir
la russe ihnen wie sie den betroffenen
gleich nach der explosion mit
schlafplätzen und lebensmitteln geholfen
haben
nach der hafen explosion waren wir es
die gehandelt haben wir haben den
menschen gezeigt dass wir uns besser um
sie kümmern als die regierung dort
drüben haben wir unser base camp
errichtet wir mussten die menschen gar
nicht mit worten überzeugt wir haben
gezeigt dass wir etwas tun und ich
glaube das ist das rezept für erfolg in
diesem land die wut auf die krise auf
korrupte eliten und die planwirtschaft
wächst mit jedem tag
lara und hussey inseln froh über alle
die sie dabei unterstützen auf die
wahrheit zu drängen
damit die menschen dem libanon endlich
erfahren wer verantwortlich ist für die
explosion für über 200 tote und tausende
verletzte tanja alarm war mit ihren mann
bei einem routinecheck im krankenhaus
sie stand an seiner seite als durch die
druckwelle die fenster
ich habe das glas auf mich zufliegen sie
und dieser lärm dieser unglaubliche lärm
dann bin ich geflogen
als ich aufwachte hat niemand
geantwortet ich bin zu ihm gegangen und
er war voll mit blut so aus als ob er
schlafen würde ich habe versucht seinen
kopf anzuheben und gesehen wie das glas
seinen hals aufgeschnitten hat es war
eine szene wie im weltuntergang kaum zu
beschreiben
ich verstehe es immer noch nicht ich
kann immer noch nicht glauben ihn nie
wieder zu sehen
es ist sehr hart natürlich habe so
vieles das ist ein buch das sie für die
opfer gemacht haben das heißt 607
lebendiger asche das ist freudig tanja
zeigt uns auch das familienalbum ihrer
new york reise ein unternehmer und einer
anwältin mit ihren zwei söhnen vor allem
für sie kämpft tanja weiter wir wollen
gerechtigkeit
wir wollen sich die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden ich kann
doch meinen kindern nicht in die augen
schauen und so tun als ob wir einfach
weitermachen kann
das system hat uns so lange im stich
gelassen
jetzt ist es an der zeit die einzige
möglichkeit das geschehene zu
akzeptieren ist wenn sich dadurch etwas
verändert
jeden tag erinnern ihre gesichter daran
wie viele fragen in diesem land noch
nicht beantwortet sind
es wirkt das würden freddy und die über
200 opfer davor warnen tatenlos
zuzusehen wie der libanon immer weiter
in die krise stürzt eine stumme
aufforderung ihrem land eine zukunft zu
geben
[Musik]